los opioides son medicamentos que se
recetan para tratar el dolor moderado o
intenso
algunos ejemplos de estos medicamentos
son hidrocodona oxicodona morfina
hidromorfona y metadona
la heroína una droga ilegal es también
un opioide para entender cómo funcionan
los opioides es importante saber cómo
siente el dolor el organismo el proceso
comienza cuando algo dañino ocurre en su
organismo la información sobre este daño
se convierte en una señal nerviosa la
señal pasa por los nervios hasta la
médula espinal y llega al cerebro
en su cerebro la señal se percibe como
dolor
los fármacos opioides afectan la forma
de sentir el dolor se adhieren a
estructuras llamadas receptores opioides
estos receptores se encuentran en las
células del cerebro en la médula espinal
y en otras zonas del cuerpo los opioides
actúan sobre estos receptores para que
sienta menos el dolor
estos medicamentos también tienen
diferentes efectos en otras áreas por
ejemplo los opioides actúan sobre la vía
de recompensa en el cerebro esto provoca
la liberación de una sustancia química
llamada dopamina que produce una
sensación de felicidad o subidón los
opioides también pueden provocar una
respiración más lenta además pueden
reducir el movimiento intestinal lo que
causa estreñimiento
para la mayoría de las personas cuando
los opioides se toman según los
recetados durante un periodo de tiempo
corto son bastante seguros y eficaces
sin embargo estos fármacos se pueden
tomar de maneras que no han sido
recetadas como tomar demasiados tomarlos
para drogarse o dárselos a otra persona
el uso indebido de estos fármacos puede
aumentar el riesgo de desarrollar
tolerancia dependencia adicción a las
drogas y sobredosis
la tolerancia significa que el
medicamento es menos eficaz con el
tiempo esto puede ocurrir cuando los
receptores opioides se vuelven menos
sensibles a los efectos del medicamento
como resultado es necesario tomar más
cantidad del fármaco para obtener un
alivio del dolor la dependencia se
produce cuando una persona tiene
síntomas al dejar de consumir el
medicamento cuando éste se retira o
usted se abstiene de tomarlo se siente
mal esta enfermedad se llama abstinencia
el síndrome de abstinencia de los
opioides presenta síntomas parecidos a
los de la gripe que incluyen inquietud y
ansiedad dolores musculares incapacidad
para dormir ojos llorosos y secreción
nasal náuseas y vómitos cólicos
estomacales y diarrea y las pupilas
dilatadas o ensanchadas
la adicción a los opioides es una
enfermedad del cerebro en la que se
tiene un deseo abrumador de consumir el
fármaco usted no puede dejar de tomar el
medicamento a pesar del daño que pueda
causarle la adicción no es lo mismo que
la dependencia se puede ser tolerante a
un medicamento o dependiente de este sin
ser adicto a él
por último la sobredosis de opioides es
una afección en la que tomar una
cantidad excesiva de los medicamentos
puede provocar síntomas potencialmente
mortales o incluso la muerte los
síntomas de la sobredosis de opioides
pueden incluir confusión sentirse muy
somnoliento o no estar alerta náuseas y
vómitos o pilas contraídas o pequeñas
inconciencia respiración lenta o
detenida y la muerte
según los centros de control de
enfermedades más de 100 estadounidenses
mueren cada día por sobredosis de
opioides
si tiene preguntas sobre los opioides o
si usted o alguien cercano a usted
necesita ayuda para un trastorno por
consumo de opioides hable con su
proveedor de atención médica